stranger things is a bonafide phenomenon
and it's charming young Cass became
stars seemingly overnight even though
their careers are even younger than they
are there are still some fascinating
factoids about each of the Netflix hits
kids like his on-screen alter-ego Dustin
Henderson Gaytan matarazzo really does
live with rare bone disorder called
Clyde Oh cranial dysplasia while he said
he has a relatively mild case he's never
developed collar bones or permanent
teeth Matt and Ross tougher co-creators
of the hit series decided to write that
detail into the show after meeting
moderato and the young actor credits
them with giving him a platform from
which to raise awareness for his
condition told you a million times my
teeth are coming in called quite Oh
cranial dysplasia before the duffer
brothers cast moderato though he had a
tough time getting considered for
Hollywood roles as a result of his
condition he did previously have some
luck on Broadway however and he also had
a bit role on TVs the blacklist in 2015
still stranger things was the first full
series to give him a shot at stardom
some kids are just born to be a part of
the biz Finn wolfhard inherited the
entertainment bug from his father an
aspiring screenwriter and while his dad
helped him develop an early interest in
movies he's now trying to use his own
newfound influence to give his old man
and in thanks to Finn's role and
stranger things in the 2017 adaptation
of Stephen King's it he's been able to
use his increased pop culture profile to
make connections along with his old man
which was one of the reasons he got into
acting in the first place aside from the
its sequel Finn landed a role in the
adaptation of the best-selling novel the
Goldfinch and joined the voice cast of
2009 teens animated Addams Family movie
on the show 11 is a young woman of few
words but in real life Milly Bobby Brown
has no trouble expressing herself with
her voice before she was 11 the British
actress had plenty of videos on her
YouTube channel singing covers of Amy
Winehouse Adele and more it almost makes
you hope that stranger things season 3
throws in a full-on musical episode
it's her impressive acting chops though
that have people excited about her
breakthrough performance as the
telekinetic super heroine of the series
after sheering off her locks to play 11
she's definitely a star on the rise at
13 she's already been nominated for two
Emmy Awards and she's got a starring
role in gods
like king of the monsters Caleb
McLaughlin got his start playing young
Simba in Broadway's run of the Lion King
around the same time gate in moderato
was on stage and lame is the pair knew
each other before stranger things in
mcLaughlin like Matarazzo can act sing
and dance and even studied at the Harlem
School of the Arts if you wanna wish
your time looking for a traitor
go ahead cuz I'm not spending my time on
her anymore
no way while stranger things brought him
to a new worldwide audience he hasn't
forgotten how he got a start tellin
Entertainment Weekly that he and
moderato were constantly singing
familiar show tunes during their
downtime on the shoot
Steve Harrington went from a bit of a
jerk to a fan favourite character over
stranger things to seasons and Joe Carey
can thank his real-life niceness for
inspiring a complete overhaul of his
character his most likable moment might
not have come from the show though and
instead resulted from Steve's visual
similarity to a character in the NBC
sitcom parks and recreation given their
shared flair for big hair and similar
facial features stranger things viewers
couldn't help but sense a connection
between kiri and Parks and Rec
jean-ralphio played by Ben Schwartz the
two actors embraced the gag and even
made a viral video confirming that Steve
is jean-ralphio secret father guys while
he was a major part of the second season
will Byers spent most of the first part
of stranger things stuck in the
upside-down
if that left you feeling like you were
missing out on seeing Noah schnap be
menaced by evil forces don't worry he
was featured in panic at the Disco's
music video for la devotee which
featured him tethered to a chair by a
satanic cult it probably goes without
saying that this video was conveniently
released right on the heels of stranger
things and is probably just the first in
a long line of projects following in the
wake of his breakout performance
Natalia Dyer literally fell into acting
when she was a child after spraining her
ankle on the first day of sports camp
her parents decided to put her into a
less physical program and she wound up
studying drama instead as a result when
she landed the role of the lovable Nancy
wheeler she'd already been in the
business for quite a few years making
her on-screen debut way back in 2009
with Hannah Montana the movie she's also
been studying language at NYU but had to
put her studies on hold due to conflicts
with filming her hit show which is a
pretty good problem for a student to
have before her ill-fated character barb
inspired some of 2016's most memorable
memes Shannon purser was working at a
movie theater once the internet blew up
with its demands for justice for barb
though purser decided to quit her day
job and give the biz a real shot in the
barb frenzy was responsible for that in
more ways than one
are you sick of that she told Glamour
she actually had to let go of her gig at
the theater once her newfound fan base
started showing up at her job however it
happened stranger things launched purser
into plenty of roles including a
recurring part as Ethel mugs in
Riverdale in the lead role in the 2018
Netflix film Ciara Burgess is a loser if
you thought Jonathan Byers seemed to
have a lyrical soul you know whenever he
wasn't taking creepy pictures of Nancy
it's because in addition to acting he's
also a musician he played drums for Brit
noise band Comaneci until 2014 when they
concluded in 18-month world tour and
called it quits it was his sister who
first prompted him to pursue acting and
his first gig was an eight-minute
advertisement for a Swiss Insurance
Company complete with the whole
storyline Heaton wasn't so lucky in
October of 2017
he missed the season 2 premiere party
after being detained at los angeles
international airport security examined
his belongings and detected a very small
amount of a substance later determined
to be cocaine heatin ended up being sent
back to the UK a gaff for which he
apologized in a public statement days
later joining are Hawkins heroes in the
second season is another young lady with
the supreme set of skills
although hers have nothing to do with
telekinesis Mack's a transplant from
California owns the high score on Dig
Dug at the local arcade under her
pseudonym Mad Max and even though some
members of the group are a little more
reluctant than others to include her she
eventually joins up with her prodigious
skateboard skills and plushy skateboard
so she's pretty awesome awesome you ever
nood spoken a word to the actress behind
all that sass Sadie Cink grew close to
Millie Bobby Brown on the set of
stranger things - despite the fact that
their characters share very little
screen time the two enjoyed slumber
parties together do edit on pop music
covers and spent downtime from the shoot
together but despite how close the pair
grew behind the scenes sync reportedly
took a lot of social media heat from
fans who were afraid max might drive a
wedge between eleven and Mike which
might have helped prepare her for the
controversy that erupted after she
revealed that her kiss with Caleb
McLaughlin toward the end of the second
season was an unscripted surprise
there's a reason Priya Ferguson was
promoted to a recurring character
between stranger things second and third
seasons her portrayal of Lucas and
Claire's sassy little sister made her an
instant favorite during her brief time
in the series sophomore run as fans
delighted in her unbridled passion for
syrup and sharp demeanor behind the
scenes Ferguson is just as intriguing
although her young career started to
flourish once she landed her role in the
Netflix sci-fi series her backup career
plan is also pretty impressive if acting
doesn't work out she has plans on
becoming a surgeon
Ferguson's other ambition is to be a
philanthropist and she's already well on
her way in
2015 the Georgia native landed a
spokesmodeling gig with United Way and
hopes to help the homeless although she
didn't start acting until her late teens
season 3 edition Maya Hawke has been a
part of Hollywood since the day she was
born
Hawke is the eldest child of actors
Ethan Hawke and luma Thurman after
spending her childhood visiting the sets
where her parents
she said she finds acting to be as
natural as breathing Hawk who struggled
in school early on thanks to her
diagnosed dyslexia earned a breakthrough
role as Jo March in the PBS adaptation
of Louisa May Alcott's Little Women
a role that was so important to her that
Hawk was willing to quit her studies at
Juilliard to take it before becoming the
well-liked lifeguard Heather in Hawkins
Indiana
Francesca rial a starred in another big
Netflix series haters back off to get
that role in her part in stranger things
though the NYU grad had to first qualify
for her Screen Actors Guild card that
meant having to start small including a
bit part on Blue Bloods where she laid
in a pile of dirt as a dead body that
hasn't stopped her from dreaming big
citing Audrey Hepburn as her ultimate
Hollywood inspiration she has
aspirations to eventually take her
television successes to the silver
screen and she's already well on her way
for her feature film debut she was cast
alongside stranger things castmate than
Talia Dyer in Karen Maine's full-length
adaptation of her short film yes god yes
last but not least we have Billy your
prototypical mean teen with a mullet no
shirt and zero respect for speed limits
he looks like a cross between Rob Lowe
and st. Elmo's fire and Jason Patric in
the Lost Boys but with fewer redeemable
inner qualities in real life de coeur
Montgomery is hardly the depraved
character he portrays on the show the
Australian native spends his downtime
making music videos and before stranger
things he starred as Jason Scott the Red
Ranger in 2017 s big-screen Power
Rangers movie in that film he's as easy
to like as Billy is to hate which shows
some pretty impressive range and
probably came as a surprise to plenty of
Mighty Morphin fans who followed him to
Hawkins his initial audition for
stranger things consisted of one very
thematically OnPoint mini film he made
for the duffer brothers in which he
quote may or may not have put on a
g-string and danced too hungry like a
wolf nabbing the role was what made him
decide to move to the u.s. to pursue his
budding screen career once and for all
[Music]